okay all right so this is like your
class each work well y'all I get more
like later they're all naked
that's a that's a cool word we use
around here it's call it Oh naked
because naked is one thing you know a
lot of people can get paid this to stand
still naked you know under saying you
could probably pay me a little bit of
mine I was standing here naked you know
you might not like it but I would do it
but to bend over and spread your ass
naked is a whole different type of
feeling first of all for five hundred
dollars you get a lot of my attention
you know poke it out four and you got to
look back at her it is five hundred you
got a keeper he said if you're a
gentleman and you're in the club and
this girl's actually twerking her life
away sweating and shaking and it's not
about convincing you that this song is
it it has more to do with than just the
ass shaking aspect of it you know I mean
getting on that pole and getting up
there and getting that money she's
making this shake she trying to make the
patrons make some shake by throwing some
money
the bar is trying to make the patrons
make some shake by making them the right
strength of drinks you know I mean so
everybody is in there trying to make
some shape fortunately for us whenever
makes them shake comes on everybody eats
I always make it right even when I was
in the street if I went in the club I
made it rain
I've seen so much money that it feels
like you're walking on plush carpet